when we walked into the airport it just
seemed very very what we were doing
became very very real
and Robert said we're late but we'll
check in so they know we're here and
then we'll separate I said okay so we
found the check into the flight that we
were that we were on there was nobody
there because we were so late everybody
who'd already booked onto that flight
we're already sitting on the plane
Robert went up and he handed in his
passport and his took it there's only 20
minutes and these chaps in plane casual
clothes appeared mr. Locke yeah oh they
look really pleased to see him no mr.
Locke mr. Locke good please come this
way we've been waiting for you and I
just assumed that they were holding the
plane up for him because he booked a
ticket and he was late so they were
going to escort him quickly onto the
plane and I couldn't I thought I've
never heard of such a thing of them
somebody getting such VIP treatment and
he's not really a VIP but how come he's
getting the VIP treatment and not me and
they asked me whether I was with him and
they said are you with with Robert Locke
and I said yes
a little good then you come this way as
well then played as well thank you very
much and we all went trotting off
together
we went all the way through the airport
down this little corridor and into this
little room
I didn't quite know why we were there
and then all hell seemed to break loose
you kind of explain what you're doing
was disoriented and I looked up to my
left and there was a board covered in
photographs and on the top of the board
they've written custom seizures and that
was the point at which I realized that
these chaps from the chatty encounter
were actually customers officers just a
book they had received a tip-off about
Robert and the top British Embassy had
told tie customs to wait for him at the
airport
what do we have and with what and I just
stood there thinking oh this is
really bad news this is not supposed to
be happiness is it can someone explain
what's going on I can speak English
Russell is she about getting out reaches
Keith I had a feeling in the morning
that it was all going to go wrong and
there lo and behold it was going all
terribly wrong but nobody was interested
in me or my bags or they didn't take my
shoes off or look in my belt or anything
like that yeah this enemy
Robert was taken behind a screen and he
came back and he said to Ruth
I've just been x-rayed and I thought I
mean that's not a good sign
and then Ruth was taken behind the
screen and she said yeah I've just been
x-rayed and I thought looks like if
they've done to they're going to do
three even though they're not searching
my bags and then they didn't search my
bags they didn't search me like I say
nobody seemed to be very interested in
me at all and then just at the end one
of them said okay we need an x-ray from
you as well did you marry off and come
with me and of course then I did begin
to panic because I thought there's no
way out of this at all
so they took an x-ray and then they said
you can take your bags and we can go now
and we left I just assumed they haven't
showed up on the x-ray and I thought
well gosh that was quite lucky wasn't it
um it obviously just hasn't shown up and
we're okay they took us to the bureau
DeShawn's because we didn't have any
money
so we went and we changed money
one
the woman who was holding the plane up
on the walkie-talkie said to me if you
still need to go to the toilet there's
one just over there and you can go now
if you want
are you sure yeah that's fine I didn't
go to the toilet I could have got rid of
what I had I could have got rid of the
drugs I should have done I shouldn't
have done it in the first place
thanks very much I thought Robert will
be annoyed at me he's bought the plane
ticket
then I'll owe him money for the plane
ticket so I just again I was thinking
I'm just gonna do this so it'll be okay
so we changed our money and walked with
this woman and she's talking to the
pilot and she's telling the pilot we're
walking down such-and-such a runway and
we'll be there within 35 seconds and
just as we were walking down this like a
black ramp towards the gate and the
plane two men ran up behind me and they
just grabbed my bag my shoulder and
dragged me back to the to the castle
Jack we do